La mission, elle est très claire,
c'est de la gagner cette campagne.
Vous allez doucement en retard,
mais moi, quand je regarde la presse,
j'ai l'impression que les jeux sont déjà faits.
Quand j'écoute le Rassemblement National
et Jordan Bardella,
j'ai l'impression
qu'il faudrait même pas rentrer en campagne.
Et bien non, c'est mal me connaître,
c'est mal connaître le président de la République.
Et moi, euh.
J'appelle tous ceux qui se reconnaissent dans le
projet européen du
président de la République,
tous ceux qui veulent défendre l'Europe de Simone VEL,
l'Europe hum hum, euh.
De Jacques de l'or,
à se mobiliser dans cette campagne.
Et je pense que vous allez être surpris
et même, je dirais. Euh,
rendez-vous le neuf/06